foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
stupid bats you're ruining date night
well
a little spoiler alert there
Batman's in the movie yeah Batman is in
the film
Jared uh you tried out different laughs
didn't you yeah Joker yeah did it was it
very difficult for you to come up with
the right laugh was it I mean what how
annoying a process is that this laugh is
an iconic thing so there was a lot of
pressure I tried a lot of different
laughs out on the streets of New York
and Toronto
yeah people just thought something was
wrong with you
yeah I had one that I knew wasn't right
it was kind of like
he
he
Ard that's not really good yeah I'm not
sure
[Laughter]
it's like a shy
all right Karen his laugh really
bothered you yeah well whenever I met
Jared he never broke character so I
would say hi I'm Karen fukuhara nice to
meet you I'm Katana and then he would
come at me with
hi pretty that was the worst impression
ever I'm sorry I'm sorry
that was pretty good yeah pretty good
it's a very good
a very good wicked witch that was
excellent Margot uh director David Ayer
surprised you on the set I think the
first day with a razor what was that all
about he he cut a chunk out of my
eyebrow
okay
um honestly I I didn't feel too hard
done by because he'd cut off Karen all
of Karen's hair actually I had heard
about to hear two feet of hair that he
just cut off cut off my hair as well oh
that's true but what is his fixation
with I mean first of all lovely why did
he need to take out a piece of your
eyebrow just I don't know it it kind of
came out of the blue and
yeah just look like I had a cut in my
eyebrows I also used to be a barber in
the Navy I mean that's the first thing
you know so there's no reason for it
right yeah
it sounds like an HR problem yeah it's a
real HR problem and you uh shaved uh
parts of your body I'm not told
[Laughter]
that's what I was told it's right here
in the research
do you want me to show the photographs I
mean what do you want
uh
I'll do what I gotta do oddly oddly it's
I I did two films in a row where I I
either waxed or shaved my entire body
and my eyebrows and I wore lipstick
which is pretty yeah two in a row on
that one I don't know what that means I
like the way you leaned in to be like
you understand don't you come
I understand completely
to have to call that one a pattern
I'm entirely hairless